as lots of people keep saying to me what
does Liverpool have to do to win the
league at this moment of time I think I
think I think you know if we can start
in June then we will pick up the season
I think that's what people want with in
football the integrity of the football
of the Premier League and the Football
League to finish what we've started and
then start again you know whether that
takes that the the following season not
starting until October but of course
we're in you know we're in over above
our heads at this moment in time nobody
really knows what's eventually going to
happen how long this is all going to
take so at the moment we're still hoping
but that might all change yeah what's
the impact on the clubs that are you
know some of the club's that are you
know in financial difficulty lots of
players I'm told are taking a pay cut
until the games restart yes
postponing their wages which is a great
idea absolutely fantastic I just hope
that the Premier League and the Football
League clubs can get together to make
sure that some of the clubs who are in
financial dire straits can be supportive
you know whether it's all the Premier
League clubs given a million pounds and
maybe the the AFL clubs giving half a
million pounds just to prop up the clubs
that are in financial trouble possibly
you know I don't I don't really know
it's one of those situations where you
know are the board of the Premier League
getting together now to discuss exactly
what is going on how we're gonna move on
from this situation how we can plan for
the future are the Football League clubs
getting together and thinking how can we
sustain what we've actually got how can
we support the players wages at this
moment in time it's a really difficult
situation it's well it was unthinkable
before this happened and now it's
actually happened how do we sort it out
it's
illustrated the Paris sport bringing
people together and now this that that
vacuum isn't that particularly the
weekends people don't know what to do
with themselves I know the men in my
households are re watching football
games or from you know previous
championships or re watching what
happened with Formula one two or three
seasons ago what are you doing
who are you do you care they're behind
you
[Laughter]
well I'm exactly the same picking up on
all max of the days and old football
games on Sky Sports as well that we've
seen before but you forget it's like
watching an old film in it you forget
how good they are at times and yeah
that's been absolutely fantastic but as
you just said there K you know sport in
our lives is just amazing really you
know you you don't know how much you
miss it until it's gone like it as at
this moment in time and like you just
said what a vacuuming you in your life
that sport brings the joy that it brings
the ups and downs the excitement
everything that comes with it we're
missing at this moment in time but we
have to understand the circumstance and
I think everybody does understand the
circumstances now a week ago people were
still going out
mingling and helping to spread this
virus at least now the message is going
through and a final thought on those
sort of crown jewels that sort of
punctuated the sporting season I'm
thinking about the FA Cup final I'm
thinking about Wimbledon I'm thinking
about the grand national without those
people are going to be pretty bereft
aren't they well I think everybody
basically understands what's going on
but they will happen again you know
we're we're in such a difficult
situation that's hard to fathom at this
moment in time
you know the one the one thing that's
become a godsend and you know okay
you're one of those key workers could
you imagine if we didn't have social
media and all those types of
things at this moment in time where
we're able to relay these messages to
people and say stay at home can you
imagine if it was 50 well not maybe 25
years ago it would just be absolutely
horrific it would certainly be a case in
a situation where people wouldn't
understand what was going on wouldn't
read a letter from the government it
would be it would be incredible so
thankfully the message is getting
through so hopefully we're going to
start as soon as possible have you been
practicing in the shower your commentary
for when you get back not quite in the
shower I've become
we're fortunately okay because my oldest
son and his wife and their two children
moved in my other son lives in next door
with his partner and they've got little
and called conic so I've become the
granddaddy of all granddad's and I am
working hard my session starts at nine
o'clock this morning you know when
you've played football for 22 years like
I am and I works with sky for 22 years
at this moment in time it is a blessing
in disguise obviously take the
circumstances out of this what being
with the family at this moment in time
and self isolating ourselves has been
absolutely incredible I can't if
football could start on Saturday I'd be
there okay give me give me the
commentary really quickly when clop
lifts the cup Jordan Henderson with his
manager Jurgen Klopp and they are about
to pick up the Premier League trophy
okay
[Applause]